when it comes to the question of who is
the greatest sprinter to come out of
Jamaica Usain Bolt tends to be the stock
answer but when it comes to World
Championship success
Shelley Fraser nice sunday saw the 32
year-old from Kingston in the 100 meters
in a time of 10 point 7 1 seconds the
first person man or woman to win four
world 100-meter titles Fraser prices
latest success coming just 13 months
after the birth of her son to be able to
have my picture life with my son you
know he's responsible for the mommy
Rockets of course and he's responsible
for a combat weld an Olympic triple jump
champion Christian Taylor is another who
knows nothing but World Championship
success the 29 year old recovered from
to foul jumps to beat his longtime rival
and college friend will clay with a jump
of 17 point ninety meters well whilst
Fraser price and Taylor are multiple
world champions it was a new feeling for
the winner of the women's pole vault
angeleka sued her over the Russian
having to compete as a neutral with a
country's Athletics Federation remaining
suspended because of doping violations
it's not really comfortable for me but
now I'm happy and I just had been both
minut I thought there was also a new
event to enjoy the next 4 by 400 meter
relay
each team fielding 2 men and 2 women in
whatever order they chose : lead going
into the final leg but the Americans
swept through to win with a world record
time and in so doing giving Allyson
Felix a 12th World Championship title
moving her one ahead of give sine bolt
is the outright leader in world gold
medals rahul Pathak al jazeera